[Musique]
dans la ville il y avait un homme
installé sur des bouts de carton à
l'entrée d'un immeuble en face d'une
école son lieu de vie depuis plusieurs
années déjà c'est hélas c'était la rue
et les élèves leurs parents le personnel
enseignant connaissaient ce monsieur et
l'appeler par son prénom
aujourd'hui on va l'appeler ted mais un
jour ted a disparu et il n'est jamais
revenu
tout le monde s'est inquiété pour lui et
tout le monde avait très certainement
raison de s'inquiéter pour lui parce
qu'il faut savoir que l'espérance de vie
d'une personne sans abri en rue et de 45
ans mais je vais pas vous laisser avec
tout ça parce qu'en fait tu es tu vas
bien il va très bien même il est en
logement aujourd'hui
depuis trois ans déjà et il impressionne
tout le monde pourtant tout avait été
essayé avec lui mais il ne s'essaie de
zone et de la rue à l'accueil de jour à
l'abri nuit de la rue à l'accueil de
jour à l'abri ni pendant huit ans ted
était un habitant de la rue aujourd'hui
ted habite son logement
qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence cette
fois-ci la réponse va vous étonner par
sa simplicité
parce que ce qui a fait la différence
c'est le logement ça semble assez
évident n'est-ce pas de lutter contre le
sans abrisme par le logement
mais en fait ce qui a fait vraiment la
différence cette fois-ci c'est d'avoir
osé le logement immédiatement depuis la
rue avec une personne aussi fragile que
ted une personne sans abri chroniques
présentant des fragilités en matière de
santé mentale et de toxicomanie
ça ne se fait que très rarement jusqu'à
présent à partir de ce logement un
processus d'insertion sociale a pu être
entamée grâce à l'accompagnement
intensifs d'une équipe
pluridisciplinaire s'agit d'une
innovation sociale qu'on appelle à zing
first ou le logement d'abord mais
qu'est-ce qui fait son caractère plus
efficace
plus efficient plus durables plus justes
c'est ce que je vais vous raconter alors
vous et moi nous croisons des personnes
sans abri entre yeux et ça peut nous
laisser l'impression que rien n'est fait
pour elle cette impression est
absolument fausse car aujourd'hui chez
nous une personne sans abri en rue peut
trouver réponse à ses besoins primaires
grâce aux efforts conjoints
d'institutions publiques et associatives
une personne sans abri en rue peut
trouver un lit pour la nuit être soigné
être nourri la problématique du sans
abrisme est gérée de manière humanitaire
est en période hivernale les moyens
alloués sont renforcées la problématique
est gérée de manière saisonnière
la majeure partie des subsides publics
sont destinés à cette gestion
humanitaire est saisonnière du sans
abrisme à partir de cette aide dite
d'urgence sociale s'organise ensuite et
je vais ici forcer un peu le trait je le
concède s'organise ensuite l'aide sous
la forme d'un escalier différentes
étapes différentes solutions
d'hébergement transitoire à durée
déterminée préparant à l'étape ultime du
processus d'insertion le logement
ce système fonctionne il ya même des
personnes qui sont très rapidement
accompagné vers le logement
mais ce système ne fonctionne pas pour
tout le monde et on retrouve ici des
personnes comme ted des personnes sans
abri chronique fragilisée dans les
domaines de la santé mentale de la
toxicomanie qui ne parviennent pas à
répondre aux conditions d'accès associés
à chacune de ces étapes se mettre en
projet diminuer voire le plus souvent
arrêter la consommation de drogue ou
d'alcool
entré en cure certaines institutions ont
assoupli leurs conditions d'accès mais
ça ne suffit pas la grande majorité des
personnes sans abri des plus fragiles ne
parviennent pas à entamer ce processus
d'insertion qui a été imaginé
elle reste des années en ruelle se
mettent à habiter la rue elle se met à
habiter des services d'urgence elle ne
cesse de s'éloigner de plus en plus du
logement individuel et elles voient leur
problématique initiale leur fragilité
initial s'aggraver la politique publique
actuelle en matière de lutte contre le
sans abrisme et discriminante
mais il ya une bonne nouvelle
je vais là partagé aujourd'hui avec vous
c'est qu'il existe une solution avec ces
personnes sans abris les plus éloignés
du logement annulons les étapes
intermédiaires inversion de processus
d'abord le logement ensuite le reste
c'est le modèle housing first ou
logement d'abord ce modèle se
caractérise par trois principes
fondamentaux
le premier le public cible le deuxième
le logement et le troisième
l'accompagnement commençons par le
public cible vous l'avez compris on
parle des personnes sans abris les plus
éloignés du logement celles pour
lesquelles on a déjà tout essayé
celle qui multiplie les fragilités dans
le domaine de la santé mentale de la
toxicomanie
celle qu'on estime comme n'étant pas
capable ou pas apte pas prêtes à habiter
deuxième caractéristique du modèle
le logement c'est le logement le plus
classique possible issue du parc locatif
public mais aussi privé la personne
signe son contrat de bail comme vous et
moi il n'y a pas d'autres conditions
d'accès à un logement
cette personne paye son loyer avec quels
revenus avec le revenu auquel elle a
droit et en dernier recours s'agira du
revenu d'insertion sociale octroyé par
le centre public d'action sociale qui
est sur le territoire fréquenté par la
personne y compris dans sa situation de
sans abri eli a droit aussi
c'est pas facile vous en doutez de
trouver du logement pour ce type de
personnes aux revenus très modestes
fortement stigmatisée mais ce n'est pas
impossible
on en a trouvé et on continue à essayer
d'impacter la politique du logement
vous avez un appartement à louer ou vous
je pense qu'on va se parler après mais
on va se parler de quoi
avec un argument vais-je pouvoir venir
vers vous et là on retrouve la troisième
caractéristique du modèle
l'accompagnement le logement ne suffit
pas avec ces personnes aussi fragilisé
il faut un accompagnement à la hauteur
de leurs besoins
l'accompagnement sera dès lors intensif
pluridisciplinaire mobile il va viser
leurs établissements on parle pas ici de
guérison on parle pas ici d'arrêter
immédiatement la consommation de drogue
ou d'alcool
on parle de rétablissement la reprise en
main de sa vie en tant qu'acteur en tant
que citoyen à partir de ses propres
ressources et à son propre rythme
l'équipe sera donc là aussi longtemps
que nécessaire
le modèle housing first est un modèle
américain qui a été initié au début des
années 90 à new york
il a pris un petit peu de temps avant de
traverser l'atlantique mais il est
arrivé en europe et dans tous les pays
d'europe dans lesquelles il existe une
politique de lutte contre le sans
abrisme il a été implémenté à chaque
fois avec un succès impressionnant
au moins 80 % de ces personnes aussi
éloignée du logement soit elles sont
toujours en logements deux ans plus tard
par ailleurs cette pratique permet de
réduire de manière significative les
coûts publics en matière de nuitées en
abris nuit d'urgence sociale et aussi en
matière d'hospitalisation
alors il était temps de tester ce modèle
en belgique grâce à la roue soutien la
secrétaire d'état à la lutte contre la
pauvreté au concours de la loterie
nationale des institutions de terrains
publics et associatifs dont je suis
issue ont initié une phase test d'une
degré de deux ans dans les villes
d'anvers gand hasselt bruxelles
molenbeek-saint-jean liège charleroi et
namur
d on appelait cette expérimentation à
zoug force belgium et je les coordonnées
depuis le service public fédéral
intégration sociale alors des équipes
d'accompagnement pluridisciplinaire
intensives ont été engagés pour
accompagner immédiatement en logements
près de 200 personnes sans abri très
chroniques elles ont passé en moyenne
cinq ans de leur vie en rue et très
fragilisés dans les domaines de la santé
mentale et de la toxicomanie
une équipe d'évaluation a été engagé au
travers des trois régions et a suivi
l'évolution de ce public là d'une partie
de ses locataires aux in furs pendant
deux ans en les rencontrant tous les six
mois
ce groupe expérimental des locataires
rosine force a été comparé à et et
d'évolution de ce groupe expérimental a
été comparée à l'évolution d'un groupe
contrôle composée de personnes sans abri
au même profil tout aussi fragile tout
aussi chronicité dans leur situation de
sans abrisme deux ans plus tard
oui évidemment dans ce groupe contrôle
ce sont des personnes qui ont continué à
fréquenter le système classique dead 2
ans plus tard où sont ces personnes que
sont elles devenues
deux ans plus tard 93% des personnes
sans abri chronique fragile accompagnés
par les équipes aux in for sont toujours
en logements ces personnes fragiles les
plus éloignés du logement nous
démontrent leur capacité à habiter elles
s'approprient leur logement elles payent
leur loyer
elle nous invite à déconstruire les
stéréotypes que nous avions les
concernant par comparaison il faut deux
ans pour que seuls 48% des personnes qui
ont continué à fréquenter le système
classique dead accède au logement les
pratiques aux in force apparaissent dès
lors comme la solution la plus rapide
pour sortie de ressortir de rue et la
solution qui permet la sortie de rue la
plus durable
autre élément que je souhaite vous
montrer sur ce graphique tout au bout à
droite vous avez une colonne qui
représente le groupe contrôle ceux qui
ont continué à fréquenter de systèmes
classiques dead 2 ans plus tard il ya
toute une série de couleur à quoi
renvoie tél on ne les retrouve pas dans
notre groupe expérimental les locataires
rosing first ses couleurs renvoie à
différents statuts résidentiel on a des
personnes qui sont en logement 48%
on a des personnes qui sont toujours à
la rue mais il ya aussi des personnes
qui sont hospitalisés qui sont en prison
sans perspective de logement à leur
sortie
d'autres qui sont dans des logements
insalubres et qui à tout moment pour
être expulsé ces données là insiste sur
la nécessité de mesures préventives
au delà de ce maintien en logement qui
est déjà un résultat incroyable on a
toute une série de données qui montrent
que ces locataires things first voient
leur estime d'elle-même augmentent et
elles gagnent en autonomie nations ce
sont aussi des personnes qui se mettent
à reprendre en charge leur santé elle
entame un trajet de soins ce qui permet
de réduire de 40 6 % les coûts en
matière d'hospitalisation
alors à partir de ces données que
convient-il de faire pour lutter
efficacement contre le sans abrisme
augmenter le nombre de lits en abris
nuit multiplier les subsides en hiver
non ces données nous invite à penser
autrement la lutte contre le sans
abrisme l'histoire de ted n'est pas une
histoire isolé faisant exception
l'histoire de ted et toutes les autres
histoire démontre le rôle moteur du
logement en matière d'intégration
sociale y compris pour les personnes les
plus éloignées du logement fondons nos
politiques publiques sur ses preuves
osons le logement avec l'accompagnement
individuel adapté et je vous parle pas
ici de mettre sur la table des nouveaux
moyens colossaux
non je vous parle d'utiliser de manière
efficiente des deniers publics
une mise en relation des coûts avec
l'impact sur le moyen et le long terme
c'est cela l'efficience quelque chose
que je vous ai pas encore dit avec je
dois vous dire avant de vous quitter
une journée d'accompagnement dans le
modèle housing first coûte trois fois
moins cher qu'une nuit en abri n'est
cette fois moins cher qu'une nuit en
prison sans vous parler des urgences
psychiatriques
dix sept fois moins cher visons dès lors
le circuit le plus court pour sortir de
la rue évitons l'installation dans les
structures d'urgence qui ne sont pas
destinées à ça permettons à ces
structures d'urgence de se ressent
trait sur leurs missions premières car
nous continuons en avoir besoin d'une
gestion humanitaire est saisonnière du
sans abrisme passons à une lutte contre
le sans abrisme et soyons ambitieux tout
en étant absolument réaliste
gagnon cette lutte contre le sans
abrisme
[Applaudissements]